good are you guys doing this is
something puzzle okay so so you guys
know that I competed in the Seattle
International Comedy Competition I like
very badly I got a 12 out of 16 to
something like that 13 * lied i wanted
to make it some better clothes insertion
13-unit like final theories up anyway ah
this guy coming up to the stage most of
those shows he does a lot of stuff he
wanted me to tell you that he's just
better than me and that's furniture he's
also a good friend of mine gonna buy now
/ hon hey guys good to be here my name
is on like that Sam Miller is hosting
the the vomiting here that's hilarious
festival I'm supposed to have all the
vehicles hey hey well I only have the
biggest guy that we've ever seen on a
small in truth I should make our hallway
situation perfect comedian you've lost
the hallways like the [ __ ] equip
invisibly threatening I love them he was
great my name is Hans can I was going to
be here i am a son of immigrants which
is a weird saying nowadays you know with
Trump banning immigrants but unsafe
don't worry about me i was born in New
Jersey that's how bad I wanted to be an
American
I don't think New Jersey my parents are
in Korea their green cards they are
residents of America but they're in
Korea so it's kind of weird Trump band
immigrants immigrants from seven
countries but we're not one of them
which is cool but I'm like yeah yeah
[ __ ] been banned immigrants [ __ ] or
in other words i hate then throwing late
stop smoking weed go by the job tell me
what to do better than you I'm American
I went to the protest at the airport I
went to the protest and it was pretty
cool I welcome the immigrants to a great
country by chanting loudly and ellora
George welcome to our country is not
what we're like all the time I love
protesting for attending as people being
so angry as something that they all
decide to collectively waste our time at
the same time margin abacus this is a
strongly we feel we're going to wait you
are dedicated I love a love immigration
I think we should be immigrating or
people should be in the greatest we
should be integrated
we should be allowing immigrants I know
that's a good thing one of the reasons
that I want to protest if you can know
what other countries to see that we're
not all Trump okay you're not a trump
another trunk we're all we're different
we're not like him I want other
countries to see that so when I travel
people don't spit on me I want to make
it easier when I travel which I
understand is not a thing that most
Trump supporters do so they look like
you know what was it a problem during
the republican national convention will
lost passports travel [ __ ] i love
mexicans okay without mexican you would
without that as the south will be buried
in a hundred years okay you can't have a
bunch of white people living in texas
y'all gonna get skin cancer the gene
pool ok i think it's a little
hypocritical to draw a line in the sand
and be like hey know what do what we
just did starting now I think Mexicans
are great they're helping our country
people i think they're destroying
america I think it'd be hilarious they
did destroy America you imagine five
hundred years from now that the plaque
would New York you to be here lies
America these be the greatest
civilization on earth but they were
brought down by people helping this
[Music]
that's what this break down our country
together Nazis never figure this out I'm
go to American know their laws i was
really acceptable maybe if you're in a
country and people helping you is
hurting you maybe that's not their fault
maybe it's the fault of your landlord
who [ __ ] cheat you out of money
that's what I'm talking about anyway I
think we're like learning English you
get out of my country when I think I
really mad at people with rope in
English that doesn't make any sense to
me that's that learning to speak English
that's just your process that's what you
wanted okay they're learning you racism
seems unrealistic guttering and getting
flustered you trying to rest their hood
no 11 speak bad english it's just hard
to learn it to class on at school can
you imagine if you adjust your algebra
skills anybody learn to find dad to get
out of my country like how Alabama and
West Virginia is trying to tell us about
heaven we're good I no one wants to go
to you anyway telling us what to do we
like immigrants stay over there a lil n
mississippi has so much confidence in a
way of life they want to make it to pay
for all Americans
when we're killing it over here the
whole country my god i'm happy about it
that I'm not Mississippi make the whole
country Mississippi why don't you
perspect Mississippi before you I try to
try to ping week another big fan of
Republicans I surprised that they're
still around how's our you're wrong
about every major issue will be a
dynasty crazy there's the Republican
Party when the person you would not give
a [ __ ] about what he said Oh bill UK
Mexicans a what you proclaim rate yeah
[ __ ] off Phil I I don't understand their
ideologies they're just like stop
immigration soft gay marriage about
tourism than what what's your vision
just want to do business really good to
each other forever no answer that's what
you get when you have a party full of
toppers and just vote for more toilet I
understand a lot of things I like
they're not correct to from the future
i'm going to come at a time machine I'd
be like hey keep elimination as simple
as the gays marry that one [ __ ] the
[ __ ] the travel you're on the [ __ ] do
dirty Jupiter you can't be buried people
who just not very
positronic efficient or anything I live
in the land I saw a lot of Confederate
flags which i think is very offensive I
feel like the Confederate flags Elena
command when it's his wife and he was
like hey remember that time goes to the
huge argument and I was trying to
divorce you yeah I'm really proud of
other that's who I am as a person
another divorce papers tattooed on my
chest my name is Hans Kim that's a real
name it's kind of a weird name that
people think it's a stage name it's not
because I was like hey how do I get
people to think about North Korea and my
parents they named me hon so they didn't
walk you to school to make fun of me
private an Asian name mission
accomplished no I do they loved my asian
a lot of my friend said weird things to
me at school when my friends leija you
got such an Asian smile unlike thanks
now we're going to think about how is
visibly different from everyone around
me every time I feel happiness I have a
weird name but I think it's even weirder
that I have a white friend named tanner
should be like hey this is my Mexican
friends and a black friend Hannah
alright so that's enough I don't
understand a lot of things that I was
doing the carpool lane I feel like the
carpool lane was like if a society was I
hey you know how you're lonely all the
time yeah do it for longer takes a long
way no think about it watch people with
friends whizzing by I am single I have
yet to find my soul mate I'd be anything
maybe a tear fall she did you get out
more loser
I love women they they got the best
genitals and we keep it ready to talk to
I like my friends are like some little
day I don't think I could ever have sex
as a man because I've never looked at a
beautiful woman I thought yeah she's all
right but is there a version of her
that's bigger in here and it was
kindness my gay friends are like Hans
you're so lucky you're not gay can you
imagine if most of the gender that you
were to track the two was an attractive
see back compilation it's hard dating as
an Asian man cuz military Asian men are
sexy doesn't make any sense to me I was
endangered women if that be I think a
get asian women [ __ ] Thank You
process definitely our children are we
very beautiful we ready today a lot of
people make fun of Asian man in their
cancer they say we have small dicks
which is a stereotype it's only negative
genital stereotypes
overlay oh you're from Canada and is it
real cold what you and it's not like
it's pretty great weight even wood it's
not like we hear that be like oh we're
on small dick ok we will find a new
hobby you want to just give up ok we
would start studying because that's what
we do I never use it like a sewing
machine I want to jump on this machine
is the girl I knew she was like my
vagina is a 3d printer and I'm pretty
cool ok that's not even accurate your
room is a beauty print your vagina
d'être maniacally not even a very good
3d printer it only present one thing
with lots of very 6-9 months to print
multi was printing of complaining I
think a band would be awful I giving
birth I'm glad we're doing it now the
men would be the worst we feel I bro I
believe so much protein and creatine
there my pregnancy six plays like 27
pounds right
what about those beans with a picture i
mention x mulch them bands this people
are working out of Jim's I don't like
that 2017 why do you need people is
doing this anyway wheelchairs and cars
you [ __ ] weirdo know while you're
working out in gyms is a guy at a nerd a
nerd and a basement Klingon your bank
account what are you going to study some
mad please stop getting [ __ ] on Bo Bo
Bo BG&E you know yourself into a better
QB or maybe used up with their shitty
orangatame dumb and weak remember that
Martha quite a big guy all you have to
do to fight a big guy is stay outside of
his reach for 10 to 20 years and
watching that I just doing sick cancer
more surface area you should do what I
do what I do is I work overtime at a job
that I have and I by a forklift that way
I can lift everything you can live a
degree in business
[Applause]
that could get prediction I prove it I
want to bring up the host of the second
I'm going over to cool at all right I'm
going to go get another way so
completely focused by donation and I
need your help because it you know times
are tough trumpet everything oh thank
you know you could way too high did you
eat money thank you oh [ __ ] now that I
really do I thought he was serious over
to give it to him he really want sweetie
hey here's the code on Billy I'll see
you guys out there getting your money
hopefully but all right I'm gonna take a
ten-minute intermission bathroom hang
out whatever and then uh you guys you
come back and it'll be comedy as dessert
and I'm going to make you some so uh yes
we please please now let's come back and
listening to me and a bunch of other
really awesome to me and you guys are
amazing thank you so much and don't
forget you donated because you love us
back